at this harvest festival in the northern
German town of Esther Stata they're
looking for the biggest pumpkin here the
winner earns respect a fair return on
their investment unlike at the bank
dwindling interest rates and rising
charges have made many people turn their
backs on banks and I'm angry at
management when I hear what's happened
in recent years what with Lehman
Brothers and the Hoopoe for Ines Bank
when you read the papers and see the
amount of money top managers have burnt
through driving the banks into ruin and
then getting bonuses meanwhile we get
less and less Betty Marx and her husband
Holger have lost their trust in banks
they don't bother putting their money in
a savings account they just spend it on
their grandchildren for instance in the
end you notice that anything you've
saved just vanishes into thin air
now we prefer to spend our money
acquiring things we might otherwise have
put on like many in their town they've
bought a home and they've fixed it up
nicely
they're only savings is found in these
coin canisters why don't they take the
coins to the bank the banks don't pay
interest like they used to when I was a
child we had an account at the post bun
that earned four point five percent
interest no I think it's a quarter or
half of a percent they want to invest
some money for their grandchildren but
they don't know where to do it
Holger Marx is angry that banks deal in
speculative trading and opaque financial
products like derivatives
he thinks banks should only earn profits
from real hard cash the fourth the
century of Teague shifts gabbatha I'm
frustrated with their business practice
I absolutely cannot understand how it's
possible for companies to engage in
short selling
many gods as an ordinary person I can
only sell you something like a cup of
coffee if I actually have something to
sell banks have earned billions through
shorting selling securities they didn't
even own at the time though a few German
savings banks do this that does not
appease savers at the moment there's a
tendency for savers to be more or less
resigned to their fate
interest rates are a rock bottom but
that's not something that a Banking
Group decides amongst themselves the
banks don't regulate the market rather
it's the policies of the ECB ordinary
people realize that the market is
flooded with cheap money but there's
nothing for them to gain it's scandalous
but we little people can't change that
we just have to live with it here
investors data what counts is what winds
up on your plate